[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
ah so you are my knight in shining armor
my name is sergey v
oh well call me esther
i have little present for tigger claws
sitting in garage
all right then fling me the coordinates
just a moment
i opened door to garage it opened from
inside too
just in case presents the car
it's a bit more than ordinary car but in
nutshell
yes just drive it there and they take
care of the rest
but don't mess this up huh i count on
you
[Music]
[Music]
so
sweden
[Music]
you could never do this
it's not him thank god quick let me know
before he returns
what no let me out
i can pay
the ncpd advice
what's a corporal qa doing messing with
the tiger claws
you work for tiger claws i told them i
would not accept their offer
in charge of hillary it's complicated
how bad for a change my mind i do not
know what is going on but
thank you you will not regret this
you got this job from akaka yes i will
pay her
she won't close in 80. and neither will
you
you would be the last person to get
bored by a couple
stuffed in a trunk oh so i thought
you never failed to
no i do suppose he who offers
most shall get his way oh
i do not mean sergey no
sadly he was outbid by another
interested
party who knows what will become of him
now
quid pro quo v quit
pro contract closed